this is a production of Cornell
University thanks again to calc thanks
Carl 30 of these webinars is more than
one person should have to take with me
Carl so hopefully appreciate you hanging
in there Cal thanks for joining us
I'll try to set the stage a little bit
for where we are right now and then talk
about some your mowing work and also I
pulled out one of your old four large
consumer trials that you did looking at
IPM and organics and stuff like that so
we'll get to that in our 30 minutes
that's gonna go by pretty quick a
student when when they were laying by
Stewart Park layman Stewart Park by the
lake took this picture of one of our
favorite plants right in the turf world
and just always nice to get a nice
picture particularly how beautiful the
sunsets have been lately around the
lakes oops
you remember how to do this alright so
in fact we've started to catch up just
in the last several days we're starting
to see that we're getting closer to
normal and you know what's really
interesting is if you look north if you
look up here in the most northern parts
of of the Northeast you see that they're
in fact a little bit ahead and you see
down here in the Maryland area Cal's old
stomping grounds our friends in New
Jersey our friends on Long Island you
know it's been really cool and and it
remains behind normal now and that's not
stopping the grass from growing in
response to the heat and humidity that
we've been getting now Cal knows I still
rely as a measure of good weed control
in the spring the the model developed
using two for Dion dandelion at Purdue
many many years ago I really liked it
just as a ballpark
some people have not found it to be
useful we found it to be a good place of
thinking about when's a good time to
make an application so that's a good
indication that the growing season is
advancing this went from a
lately read a week ago two completely
green in almost a week so obviously
being able to get out there and know
these conditions is going to be
important it's starting to get dry the
marine layer over the coastal areas of
the northeastern sort of prevented some
et but once it burns off you can see
that we're pretty much tickly in the
Norton in northern New York for those of
us you know up here we're starting to
fall behind in in rainfall and and et et
is reaching its peak conditions and you
can see now throughout much of the North
here right ROG of this north
we're in excess of an inch to an inch
and a quarter you know you're talking
about losing a significant amount of
water from your turf system everyday and
if your lawns are on sandy soils they're
going to need some kind of supplemental
irrigation to meet their requirements to
maintain active growth now you may not
want to maintain active growth and
that's a different question now the heat
stress is starting to build up across
the Northeast and you can see that vein
of heat stress that were experienced
around the New York metropolitan area
down into Maryland soil temperatures are
warming but again you know what's
fascinating to me is that they're
warmest out here to the west creeping in
to the 70s at the two-inch step so
you're going to see a lot of weed
germination a lot of crabgrass
germination throughout this region it's
going to start coming on fast as is the
growth of the turf so let's talk about
that as we I set Cal up for our
conversation today we've used this we
stopped using this chart four or five
weeks ago called because we weren't
going anywhere
five weeks in a row it didn't seem like
we could get out of or above-average
temperatures above 50 and now throughout
much of the Northeast where regularly we
just went through about a week of
experiencing temperatures in that peak
range of photosynthetic activity for our
cool season grasses right for our cool
season grasses now where Cal has a part
of his state in the transit
zone so he's gonna be interested in warm
season grasses and he has to sort of pay
attention to those as well but for us up
here there really isn't any impedance to
top growth and growth of the plant and
top growth in particular so you often
see and many of our Cornell publications
have this bimodal growth habit where you
get a significant growth surge in the
spring a decline in the summer months
when irrigation and watering and heat
obviously the growth potential is going
to go down as the temperatures go well
above average in the 70s and then
there's this resurgence of growth again
right this resurgence of growth again
that we say occurs in the fall so we
call this bimodal right 1/2 right and we
see this decline in the summer months
usually from heat drought alright so
there's a very typical picture that we
see from the landscape that I took just
wandering around and and you can see
that the leaving clippings on the lawn
is pretty common now there's a lot of
conversations to have it this time of
year but how we mow is a big part of it
now there is an old piece of work from
the 50s that has indicated cool season
grasses can produce up to about 75
percent of all their top growth in the
first six weeks of the season
now this was perfect fodder for good
scientists like Cal and his colleague
Aaron Aaron Patton and I don't know
Quincy but I'm assuming as a member of
the team or was a member of the team
there Purdue they did this great work
that they published back in 2016 looking
at different grasses mowing practices
that reduce mowing your crime it's now
before we sort of get into this
wonderful study right we're setting the
stage now everybody's mowing it's hard
to follow the 1/3 rule but if you are
able to you can cut your mowing needs at
least by the the the work they did in
this study for a year by 30% now when we
talk about the grasses that cow was
looking at in this trial right there two
grasses that you'll find many grasses go
find growing in in his region of the
country
but further study it was tall fescue in
Kentucky bluegrass characterized by low
slow meet moderate and fast growth rates
and I thought this was absolutely
fascinating a lot of these experimental
name and now the cultivar name sold and
of course you might notice some of these
varieties from things you normally see
so SoCal much like a lot of turf grass
researchers over the last decades
spending a lot of time collecting
clippings and demonstrated across the
species that as we've expected we get
quite a bit more clipping production or
significantly more clipping dry matter
yield in the spring than in the summer
than in the fall and then by species
again I was a little surprised by this
Cal and this what I'll probably bring
you in now have you talked to us about
this a little bit let me go back to
where I was sorry about that I want to
go back to that no that's not where I
want to be I want to be here I want to
be here can you see that not yet stay
still just you're a mess yeah it's your
face just my phone I got a share sorry
sorry watch that up there we go here we
go so this doesn't look like bimodal
growth to me pal unless unless we're
talking about summer being a mode you
want to talk a little bit about what you
saw here and and the big differences
between spring summer and autumn between
well especially in spring and and the
reason I'm interested in this I don't
know a little bit about our conversation
yesterday with Brad Park about Kentucky
bluegrass types some grow better in the
spring some better in the summer you
want to talk a little bit about this
tall fescue Kentucky bluegrass
difference that you observed here so
yeah and you know first and foremost I
probably need to give some you know
acknowledgement to Quincy you know
Quincy as the was the master student at
the time and he's currently a PhD
student here with dr. Patton but you
know I think you know the genesis for
that particular study was Aaron had
tended I believe the ETS meeting you
know in the early in the early 2010's
and was looking at these different you
were finally at a point that we were
we're starting to get some separation
between you know slow medium and fast
growing tall fescues you know we've read
tall fescues at that point we'd always
had up to that point you know all those
categories at Kentucky bluegrass is and
you know I suppose the fine print with
this particular with this particular
graph is this is irrigated turf okay and
I think that that plays Frank that plays
a lot into that bimodal growth curve
that we see because you know if the plan
is under stress you know we're
definitely going to get that dip in the
summer months so this this was irrigated
turf for obvious reasons that you know
we're trying to parse out the mowing
requirements and you know we're all
operating underneath this umbrella of
sustainability right and so we're
looking at you know what can we do to
reduce mowing irrigation fertilizer
pesticides all those other kinds of
things but in order to do a mowing study
appropriately the plan actually needs to
be actively growing correct well of
course you don't want any limitations to
grow that's for sure
right and because because that would
throw off the data and you know
reviewers like you and me we'd be all
like well let me put you on a spot well
let's speculate for a second here
nobody's watching no one's gonna listen
let's speculate under drier conditions
what would you expect here let's say you
irrigated
at a deficit and I know you've played
around with this as well with you
irrigated at a deficit does this graph
change I would agree with you I would
think it would agree and it would change
I would say that the edge would probably
be given to the tall fescue in that
particular situation because the tall
fescue is probably going to continue to
chug down the tracks a little bit longer
than the Kentucky bluegrass is right
right I think the other thing to look
into if you do look into that article a
little bit more closely you know there
was one that really slow growing
Kentucky bluegrass in their prosperity
yes that thing is crazy slow I mean we
talk about watching paint dry
in terms of
Kentucky bluegrass covering in that
first year but that particular cultivar
if you look at the data for the two
different years really really big
differences and it wasn't until year two
but to your point we still look at this
and we see definitely with the with the
with the tall fescue I could buy into
you said 74 75 percent of all top growth
occurs in the first six weeks
that's that probably is fairly
consistent with the tall fescue but we
really don't see that bump in the autumn
months do it we don't see sort of that
peak in the spring kind of goes down and
then we don't see that paul and in all
months right so and so as that
translates to mowing right as that
translates the number of mowing events
again important to note was irrigated
important to know they you know there
are different varieties of of grasses
we're dealing with but the fascinating
thing was I thought the fastest Kentucky
bluegrass was still much slower than the
than the the slowest tall fescue in dry
matter yield that was a graph I didn't
put in here but this is the number of
mowing scale this this is from March
till November and you know your Mona
thirtysomething times a year now how
many times do you looks like yeah it's
about it's about 30 you know or our our
growing environment is probably close to
what you get and you know when people I
do bring that up quite a bit to people
is how many times do you think you
really mow I don't think people pay
attention to that it's usually 25 to 30
for our growing region right yeah for
sure I would say it depends you get to
the city and Long Island it's can be 30
to 35 you get up here it's usually 28 to
32 something like that but either way
you can see what I thought was
interesting is that even with some of
the slow in the moderates the the mowing
frequency is every two weeks even in the
spring yeah following the one-third rule
and that's there to me that's what I'm
trying to get across
here that there are these differences
there are these changes between grasses
but fundamentally that 1/3 rule does it
seem to suppress growth yeah ooh that's
a good question and you know I look at
that 1/3 rule for lots of pieces and one
would be you know do I need a mower
don't I need to mow right and then what
you know most of us are oftentimes
thinking about plant health because you
know I think that the whole
recommendation you know if you go back
into the literature on on the 1/3 rule
was don't compromise the root system
right right and so that's a piece of it
but I think more importantly from the
consumer side they're thinking in
aesthetics ok and if you're thinking of
aesthetics because you don't want that
picture you showed with all those
clippings on a surface because
supposedly those clippings contribute to
thatch right when we know that's not
true
it looks unsightly if you care about
your you care about your turf and so
that's where I think some of that
one-third rule kind of comes into play
but look once he did a lot of work on
this because there's a couple different
mowing programs that weekly program he
was actually doing the 1/3 rule and it
was it was it was constantly evaluating
those turf plots yeah and and I you know
my sense was that anytime you're
violating the 1/3 rule you are getting
that big drop in root growth and again
we are starting to see we heard we have
heard from golf course superintendents
as well that that dramatic drop in
growth has now been associated with some
root pathogens they they were taller
they were using more growth regulators
they added some stress by and violated
the 1/3 rule a little bit and the next
thing you know they've got root problems
so these things are intimately linked
now you also did some you know this was
you know this was a fasten it was a
really good study wow oh my goodness
gracious
we just rested a lot of we don't see a
lot of academics taking on cost right
and again I got to give some you know
acknowledgement in respect to my my
entomology colleague here at dr.
Richmond I'm he's he's really in
addition
being a great entomologist he's just a
good ecologist
in terms of what he you know thinks
about and you know this study here with
Victoria it was a master student at a
time
but she did a really it was elegantly
simple basically four different programs
the do-nothing program you know organic
products that were available at a time a
consumer program for you know the Scots
basically four-bagger type of program
and then an integrated pest management
program where you did some scouting to
look for different potential pests and
in putting some thresholds in place to
decide whether or not the treat or not
and so you can kind of see here the four
different programs so the top left
that's the IPM program with the letter A
that'd be the consumer program the Scots
you know consumer program that you can
get the big-box centers the natural
organic program which had things like
corn gluten and you know some of the
other kinds of things that will be out
there and basically they do nothing
program or as some people like to refer
to it as the freedom law and right you
know you're free from doing anything and
we've talked about that except mom well
you still need it well some of those
freedom loans they they mow infrequently
as well it's a mess but in this study
you mowed frequently they did these were
regularly mowed I believe three inches
you know a cool season lawn mixture and
you can kind of see what's happening
here but that that that economic piece
and that was probably the real take-home
message from this paper and this this
probably hasn't gotten as much traction
as it as it as it could out there but
this idea that you know a professional
lawn care company could instead of
taking that prophylactic approach to
indiscriminately applying pesticides
whether they're needed or not you're
pre-emergent herbicides insecticides all
those other kinds of things
but simply by scouting there actually
was a potential return on investment and
a potential reduction in some of the
products that might be needed to be
applied to the law well there certainly
is a gap here where if I'm going to be
traditional and go with Scots I could
charge twenty five hundred if I'm in the
lawn care business and
the the 1900 calc this included labor as
well right that was the big cost yeah if
you go into that article and she did a
real nice job trying to tease out you
know what those costs would be but the
product cost went down but labor costs
for a train
you know assistant technician or
something and that can be expensive
labor is expensive we know that and and
and I guess did the thing that was
interesting to me was that you know how
does this work when you're deploying
people out into into a region you know
visiting more than is there going to be
I don't recall exactly did they take
transport costs and things like that
because you have to visit more now this
is a consumer not a professional so so
this would be you know that the idea was
to to look at the idea of having
somebody a technician coming to your
lawn so if you you know employed some
sort of like Frank's lawn care company
that has you know 18 people working for
him driving around and their Prius is
you know of course invited conservation
minded but checking on a property in
deciding ok hey we've got one area that
doesn't eat treated here you know take
taking into account micro environments
all those other kinds of things or hey
there's just one Pat yell in that states
here we don't need to treat the entire
law it was it was those kinds of things
and and ultimately what I thought was
interesting is clover came on like crazy
in these in these plots what what are
you this has been a constant theme
forced upon the industry and now
embraced by the industry and now
beginning to be studied by scientists
what the heck is it with culver if we've
been sort of keeping this planet bay and
now any kind of variation to what we do
and it seems to be a predominate species
in northern lawns you know it's
interesting how competitive that
particular plant is right and you know
we I had a grad student a couple years
ago we were looking at some of those
micro clovers as a potential for
self-feeding lon and dr. munch I was
doing some work down at the University
of Kentucky in the mid 2010 is also with
some of those micro
clovers and it was interesting in the
sense that sometimes when you tried to
keep it it wouldn't stay around but in
situations like this they just naturally
invade invaded into the plots right and
it is an indicator weed for you know
under fertilized turf so that could be
part of it as well but I we've got a lot
of blooming right here in West Lafayette
today well and I would be remiss if I
didn't use some of this work to launch
into crabgrass discussion as well Carol
I know back in your previous life
returned oden you played around with
crabgrass you don't do any lawn work
anywhere in your neck of the woods
you're under heavy crabgrass goose grass
pressure out there you can you live with
that I don't see crabgrass in these
plots and I'm wondering did corn gluten
meal work is it something that we're
maintaining density in these plots that
were able to keep the crabgrass at bay
because I would have thought I'd have
seen a bigger crabgrass issue in this in
this particular trial can you comment
yeah and and so you know one of the big
differences and I grew up in the
mid-atlantic so I you know I know I know
deep humidity and crabgrass in an
Atlantic is very very different than it
is here in the Midwest I mean we could
have it but it's not like it is done in
the Ohio River Valley or in the Mid
Atlantic
you know these plots at three inches
that that was enough to kind of keep it
out but we do not have the pressure at
our at our turf facility like we did at
the University of Maryland or even at
Virginia Tech it was much much worse out
there but that three-inch mowing height
plus you know products like the Scots
consumer products or the corn gluten
could sufficiently keep out the
crabgrass in those plots so what about
mowing night let's bring it all back to
the mowing height and weeds I know you
probably played around with their note
and when you were there he was messing
around with mowing Heights and crabgrass
I know you've played around with mowing
Heights and nutrition over the years
what about mowing Heights and crabgrass
we control three inches is too height
you like for lawns isn't it I you know I
personally I'm closer to three maybe
even three and a half inches in my own
lawn but it's it's it's one of those
things it's a little bit of
preference I have one individual in my
household not to be named which he/she
actually says the lawn is too high for
her I think you can figure out who that
is that same person I think he might be
the same person could be it could be in
this household we have we have three
female dogs and I have a daughter and a
wife so you know there's there's five
potential females it could be
nonetheless I do like to keep my low and
higher for that reason of trying to keep
something crabgrass out and as you're
mowing it listen if you're keeping it at
two inches that means you've gotta mow
it when it gets to three at this time of
year it's a great you want to give me a
guess you want to give me a guess at how
quick I gotta mow that it's probably
every four days to keep it where it
needs to be and and then every four days
I'm opening up the canopy again and
giving chance for light to penetrate and
that is part of the issue of why mowing
height keeps weeds at bay is not just
that it grows it's that it keeps the
canopy shaded for a while and I've
started to put some things together in
my little you know gray cells up north
here in my head you know autonomous
mowing we're constantly clipping a cow
we're constantly keeping the canopy open
my pigs they find an area they
constantly chew it they constantly wear
it down and I see more weeds there I
don't
I think it's allowing the grass to grow
longer that extends the time you have to
open up the canopy is as much as the
control as the height itself thoughts I
you know the idea of these autonomous
mowers I think could be a real big
game-changer if they can get those
figured out because I think it's gonna
allow us to keep them working consistent
canopy and it might even reduce some of
the stress if we're nipping off the leaf
tips instead of taking a whole one-third
chunk if we're just nipping off those
leaf tips you know every couple three
days that might be helpful as well but
again mow mow it high and let them lie
right and that's a place to take
questions call do we get
any questions yeah and we you guys were
touching on him earlier about root
growth Dan shibez asking about you know
that typical graph you see in a textbook
that's the bimodal and it's got the top
growth and the bottom growth and he's
kind of asking you know have we proven
you you measure all these clippings now
we have a better idea now top growth
what do we know about bottom growth in
relation to that does it show the same
patterns as top growth have we done
anything there and any any comments on
that well that's a really good question
that I'd expect my pal Dan shied to ask
and so let me go back to the chart that
we typically use right I mean here's the
problem not enough people study roots
and I know why I tried it twice and I
said I'm done with this and I don't know
if Cal you feel differently about it but
I'd say first off we don't know a lot
about roots cuz they're they're not as
easy to study as the top parts what you
see here is a depiction of our best
thinking of how and even some of the
latest research that we see with Bing
gurus done at Rutgers where there are
some grasses that can root under warmer
soil temperatures but typically root
growth is most active when it's cooled
there's been some work that's been done
looking at a you know violating the
one-third rule and a lot of it was in
pasture work years ago with the way they
let him graze and they'd see a thing of
root growth but I'll just set the stage
Calum asked you do you know the answer
to Dan's question about what do I know
about root growth I don't know the
answer and I think it is so complicated
quite honestly because you have things
you know everything's driven by
temperature right I mean so you've got
you know the soil temperature piece of
that but then you have this whole thing
of different soil environments and
different oxygen status of the soil you
know back to you know one of my mentors
you know Pete Byrne Odin and he had a
postdoc working with him doctor foo
doctor foo did a whole bunch of root
scans looking at summer cultivation and
that's that's an interesting paper to
kind of pull out some day and you know
looking at different ages of the plant
and that summer cultivation and whether
some are cultivation has some
but those root scans were painful and
doctor doctor foo spent a lot of time
trying to pull all that information out
of there but like you said if I don't
have the mental roots I tend to stay
away from all that is exactly right and
I do think yes
yeah and I'm here's what I would say
about rooting I would say number one if
you got a soil that it that a plant will
root deep into that's not restricted by
compaction has plenty of nutrition
waters moving down through and all those
things are good I'm not entirely sure
how some you know moderation of the 1/3
rule is going to dramatically impact
something like that I think if you did
it constantly
it would probably lead to some reduction
it would probably lead to a balancing
effect but I I'm with Cal I actually
think soil things are much bigger than
mowing things but I do think there is
this dramatic shock Pam Sherrod said it
to us in a sports turf thing a couple of
weeks ago mowing is stress mowing is
stress and it appears that following the
one-third rule seems to be that sweet
spot where we know top growth is
moderate I guess we can assume root
growth if it's unimpeded is going to be
moderate as well all right Carl what's
next
hey can I do it can I do a quick
shameless plug can I show you actually
here yes how does that uh-oh you want to
share your screen yeah great Carl can
you give it Dumbo yeah I'll give it to
you real quick I'll make it close
all right bingo
[ __ ] update hair is it there yeah yeah
you go on the bottom share screen
hopefully uh should allow your share
there we go okay so here's our here's
our stainless plug so we have we
launched this app about two years ago
there's actually a whole suite here it's
Purdue turf dr. tree doctor or a flower
doctor all these other kinds of things
we just type in Purdue you know whatever
doctors you can download these things
for a buck ninety-nine they're really
neat in the sense that they are resident
on your mobile device and so once you've
paid a dollar for ninety nine whether
you have mobile phone access or not you
can scroll through pictures of all the
different you know insects disease we
passed all those are the kinds of things
in your lawn so I wanted to kind of just
put that out there for people less than
a cup of Starbucks coffee you know
proceeds benefit the pretty turf program
so you know we'll get this big spike in
people downloading this that's correct
and what is that little chart there up
in the right kale chart on the right on
that slide that that's a bluegrass with
irrigation yeah
yeah so I'm gonna get to that so sorry
about that yeah so this this I also
wanted to highlight some work that we'll
have coming out here this was one of my
master's students Jada pollen but she
spent two years basically irrigating
similar to Quincy study but we had
drought susceptible and drought tolerant
tall fescues and Kentucky bluegrass and
she used a green color threshold seventy
percent green she would water the plots
twice a week and basically what we had
here is the green lines are the tall
fescue blue lines being Kentucky
bluegrass and that red line that linear
red line being has set it and forget it
Monday Wednesday Friday program but just
showing the difference between tall
fescue and Kentucky bluegrass irrigation
requirements again we continue to try
and push for more tall fescues for a lot
of these properties for less fertility
and also less water use but just wanted
to kind of share some of that want that
you know that is such cool work because
the first thing I think is well look if
you just pay attention a little bit how
much water you save yeah right just what
a bluegrass right look at just paying
attention saves you some water
and then a little bit more if you've got
some grasses maybe more if you put a
soil moisture meter maybe more if you
tolerate a little more browning to shoot
a 50 percent maybe and before you know
it you realize in some of our climates
we need just supplemental maybe one deep
a week if we've got a halfway decent
soil this is such important work I'll
you're gonna you're gonna suck he'll be
gonna talk about this at the agronomy
meetings the crop meetings in the flow
we've had--we've
she said the poster and I think last
year did in the world presentation so
this this should be getting out into our
literature sometime this year's our
hopes and again I think if we had some
sort of a effort across the United
States like the graph he showed earlier
you know there's a lot of water loss and
potential water needs up your way but
you know it's right plant right place
right and so if we're looking for water
conservation we've got some grasses that
you definitely don't need to be watered
quite as much I think what's really
interesting here is look it's almost 30
days until the tall fescue actually hit
that threshold of 70% green that those
plants need to be watered so this was a
rainout shelter study but again we've
got some work and when you think about
the actual number of days in the last
five years an actual number of times
we've gone more than 30 days without
rainfall I can't even think you'd find
one in the Northeast certainly the last
two years you haven't found one maybe in
the last five it's barely so we've said
a lot to people maybe you don't need to
irrigate as much for kill there's also
an industry that you know needs the
grass to keep growing and and consumers
want a particular lawn and and a
striated your traditional way of doing
it and this is the progressive way of
doing it but I think that conventional
schedule Monday Wednesday Fridays we got
to figure that one out right yeah but we
saw I think the Senate and forget it is
exactly the mentality we have there I
call we're at wrenching hour how much
time any questions okay I think we're
we're all set we did have a question and
maybe we're not going to get out of this
webinar series without asking it but
Michaels asking about dogs and urine
any any turf species that are immune to
the dog spots that you're in burnout
spots he's asking about tell fescue
specifically but come trooping playing
around with this Cal years ago we did a
few things I think our colleague up at
North Dakota dying might have done a
couple studies looking at some of these
things but I personally just
observational e anecdotally with three
dogs
I got 3.3 female dogs a big female dog
don't pee on a tree they squat and pee
correct and my my anecdotal observations
is there's a summer stress piece of this
too and so this time of year we
generally don't see that I don't see the
dog spots when we get to July and the
soil temperatures are warmer the plants
potentially under stress I you know we
really haven't changed the dog's diet
maybe they're drinking slightly less or
more I don't know but that's the time of
the year that I usually see the injury
so you think it's seasonal as much as
the burn from the urea as well
well I'm people talk about you know
ammonia volatilizing variety different
things but there's no easy answer there
there's no easy answer let's be honest
ya know well the easy answer might be
better yeah well for the cool season
warm season the warm season grasses will
be a little bit better won't they
I would think so I would think so but we
still need to find somebody fun that
work right right
alright we're good on questions Carl
kale oh good I'm good
great to see you thanks for taking the
time appreciate Carl Frank thanks
everybody for watching we'll see you in
the fall when the grass stops growing
well we'll get back to the same point
we'll see so thanks everybody for
joining thanks
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu